foreign
[Music]
and welcome to Google Cloud next isn't
it great to be live again
our goal has always been helping you
deliver greater value effortlessly
at Google our customers feedback shapes
the evolution of our products and
services
from the early days of app engine
through the invention of kubernetes and
Google kubernetes engine
and learnings leading to cladron and
Google distributed cloud
customers have always been at the center
of everything we do
in our journey we learned it's never
about one specific feature or another
instead we engage with empathy
understanding the expectations
challenges and most importantly what
success looks like for you
and we are living in exciting time
what's possible is rapidly changing and
the role we all play in our business
success Rises
this is true whether you are working in
a small company or large in retail
banking or gaming
anywhere in the world which means the
expectations from all of us change
we are expected to deliver on speed
skill and security
we need to provision infrastructure
instantly a deploy application faster
ensure compliance across the software
life cycle
ultimately leading to faster Innovation
cycle and Engineering productivity
cloud has become the destination for all
organizations to remain innovative
and we are all expected to do more with
less right
the reality is that there is an
unprecedented demand to use the cloud
for all kinds of workloads
today let me tell you what we've been
working on to be the best partner for
you
whether you build AI applications and
create new experiences or enhance
existing Enterprise capabilities we aim
to meet your requirements today and
offer flexibility for the future
starting with AI we are at a pivotal
moment in our journey where AI can
deliver tangible value in every industry
Google's AI acceleration platform can
help you in this journey
it is open and accessible across all
layers
meets diverse customer needs and offers
the widest choice of purpose-built AI
Hardware
it is designed to meet the needs of
every AI workload and every customer
type from foundational model Builders to
tuners to Consumers
by the way many customers are already
using gke for their AI workloads like
Equifax Spotify and molecule
typically there are three core features
of kubernetes that make it well suited
for AI workloads
using open and standard API in
kubernetes we can smoothly Port
workloads between laptop
Data Center and Cloud
this portability is very important for
the IML and HPC communities
it enables you to reliably reproduce
results
kubernetes also scaled from a single
workstation to thousands of nodes
gke can scale to 15 000 nodes it
supports gpus Auto provisioning auto
scaling making it super easy to scale up
and down training and serving workloads
you can focus on model building and
training without having to worry about
underlying infrastructure and
compatibility issues
you can increase productivity by freeing
up users from managing their own
workstations servers and VMS with
kubernetes
as you heard from Thomas yesterday we
are excited to announce support for TPU
on gke
support for cloud TPU V4 is generally
available and v5e is now in preview
this enables all of you who use our
industry-leading ppus to benefit from
the gkey capabilities you are familiar
with and love
generative AI
is not only transforming software
development but also it operations as
evident from industry research
gen AI Solutions like duetai shortens
the distance between brainstorming and
execution getting you closer to the end
goal
and here is a demo of how to add Ai and
gke come together to help make platform
Builders and operations teams more
productive
what you can see here is how duetai and
so specific questions and assist with
creating a gke cluster by providing you
the necessary terraform Scripts
I love how intuitive and helpful it is
and I can't wait for all of you to try
it out
together with AI workloads modern
workloads can deliver Superior customer
experience for your customers and it's
all about containers and serverless
every organization is using containers
it is expected that by 2027 more than
that 90 percent of organizations will be
running containers applications in
production
this is a significant increase from
fewer than 40 in 2021
we are in the post VM era containers are
the present and the future
and over the past 20 years we innovated
leading to our Google Cloud products and
best practices
starting in 2003 with Borg which is our
internal container orchestration system
the inspiration to kubernetes to today
with products like cloudron and gke
here is a quick video showing some of
the reasons why customers choose Google
Cloud managed container platforms
Cloud run
fully managed
containers abstracting away all
infrastructure management whether you
own event-driven long-running services
or deploying containerized jobs to
process data Cloud run automatically
scales your containers up and down from
xero this means you only pay when your
code is running you can write code using
your favorite language framework and
libraries package this up as a container
run gcloud run deploy and your app will
be live provided with everything it
needs to run in production and if you
ever need to run outside of cloud run
Side Run workplace are portable thanks
to cloudrun using an API compatible with
kubernetes
so the next time you're wondering where
to run your containerized workload keep
Cloud run in mind
kubernetes has gained immense popularity
for its ability to enable businesses to
run and manage apps at scale and gke is
the most scalable and fully automated
kubernetes service using gke means
having Google Engineers take care of
implementing all of the recommended
practices for kubernetes so your
developers can focus on building the
application that run on top of
kubernetes
autopilot but default and recommended
way to run containers from gke takes
this further than any prior kubernetes
offering
we can help customers achieve a promise
of true workload portability between
serverless or kubernetes runtimes public
private or Edge Cloud providers and
locations without compromising
consistency security or velocity
as you saw Google Cloud can deliver
Simplicity and automation through Cloud
run leading industry-leading serverless
solution and gke the most scalable and
automated service
and unlike the competition we have made
significant Investments to make it easy
to use both Cloud run and GK why to
choose we don't want to force you
choosing one or another
we designed Cloud run to make running
containers in the cloud as simple and as
fast as possible
there is no infrastructure to manage no
compute cluster management or
connectivity management required
and it allows you to go fast a developer
is able to deploy a cloudron
microservice in seconds
you just need to bring your containers
and we handle the rest including scaling
to zero
for example around the time of the
announcement of the Queen's passing in
September 2022
BBC saw some huge traffic spikes
during the largest Spike within one
minute they went from running 150 to 200
container instances to over one thousand
and the infrastructure just worked
imagine how it is to look at your screen
and just see everything work without you
needing to lift the finger
and there's a great example of this is
recently launch support for sidecars in
Cloud run
sidecars can make it much easier to
integrate Cloud run Services into your
existing cloud service ecosystem
whether you use a third-party logging
and monitoring service or network
proxies for advanced networking
functionality
you can now integrate your Cloud run
service with this third-party extension
simply by deploying a sidecar container
this makes your developer more efficient
and your Cloud deployments easier to
operate
customers such as NASDAQ and Etsy are
already ripping these benefits by
bringing in their Envoy open Telemetry
and manageable methods integration to
easily extend cloudron's native
environments
it's been amazing to witness what
customers like kerafor have built with
gkey and Cloud run
many have simplified their architecture
improved operational efficiency and
lower the total cost of ownership
to expand the impact of containers
relaunch anthos in 2019
as a platform to manage gke containers
XR GK clusters and virtual machines
consistently
to help you build and run more than
opposite scale
we were the first cloud provider to
miscast to meet customers where they are
when we extended gke to hybrid and
multi-cloud environments with anthos
anthos includes powerful managed open
source components to help secure
workloads enforce compliance policies
and provide deep Network observability
and troubleshooting
over the years antos has evolved into
the core technology powering the next
evolution of container platforms
everywhere
today you can enter you can access antos
capabilities through Google kubernetes
engine gke and Google distributed cloud
as we saw more workloads running on gke
and more teams build on gke
a set of new requirements came to light
as a platform team how do I support
dozens of teams velocity and still give
the organization the guarantees they
need to address security risks or
availability
many customers find themselves
challenged to manage multiple
environments across multiple teams
they not only want to operate
efficiently and securely
but also move faster with lower costs
today I'm excited to announce the next
evolution of container platforms GK
Enterprise Edition
now you can scale across multiple teams
to increase velocity Support Compliance
requirements and save with a managed
container platform
these are made possible by bringing our
Decades of container Innovation into gke
the integrated and intuitive container
platform
these capabilities will be available
through the new Premium Edition of gke
starting November 15 2023
starting next week all anthos and Google
Cloud customers will automatically get
access to GK Enterprise Edition
in preview and other customers can reach
out to their account teams to try them
out
customers like Equifax and Ulta beauty
have already benefited from the
Enterprise Edition of gke
Equifax cloud data fabric built using
gkey Enterprise has ingested and
processed 250 billion data points across
eight geographies generating more than
two billion in Revenue
they've simplified the management of
more than 200 clusters using Fleet
Management while also enforcing
governance and security policies
on the other hand Ulta beauty modernized
a legacy e-commerce platform into
containers and microservices built from
the ground up on multiple GK clusters
with gkey Enterprise Ulta beauty leaves
the heavy lifting to Google and keeps
its developers productive with
self-service and a suite of managed
services such as service mesh security
and governance
as a result also delivers the best
customer experience for its Digital
Store of the future
and while you're on the show floor
please visit one of our gke Enterprise
launch Partners to learn even more
these valued partners are all standing
by to explain how gkey Enterprise is
already helping their customers
modernize two containers safely and at
scale
well we covered how Google Cloud can
help you run AI more than an Enterprise
workload in the best possible way
it is also important to manage and
operate them on a day-to-day basis
this is why Google Cloud offers Cloud
operation Suite
we designed Cloud logging and Cloud
monitoring to work with gke with zero
effort
to either collect metrics and logs or
manage the life cycle of collection
agents
we present a consistent set of signals
to all personas
whether they are checking the health of
a resource visualizing Telemetry or
troubleshooting incidents
based on feedback from all of you we are
now extending these capabilities with GK
interactive troubleshooting playbooks
these playbooks are integrated in the GK
user experience and simplified
troubleshooting GK infrastructure issues
with guided flows
for example let's say you're seeing an
unscheduled pod error in GK
these playbooks will provide an
opinionated path to investigate the
resource metrics
the right configuration threshold
correlate change events and help you
identify the reasons for failure
the metrics and logs needed to analyze
this incident will be available in one
place
well I think that by now you probably
are tired of hearing from me
and it's my pleasure to invite some of
your peers in the industry who have
partnered with us to elevate their
operation to the stage so welcome
welcome basil Omer Laura and Cameron
thank you thank you so much looking
forward for this conversation
uh so Laura you've been on a journey of
modernization a big shift in Arvest Bank
for the last two years when you reflect
back what have been fundamental for the
success of this project yeah thank you
um there's been two really key
components to success the first key
component would really be having a
business strategy and then making sure
you tie that road map and even your
migration plan to that business strategy
you want to know where you're going so
everybody knows the direction it also
helps set priorities which is a really
important component of it I would say
the second piece of it is really
actually upskilling and reskilling so
bringing everybody along for the ride
how do you get everybody on the bus and
making sure they're comfortable with it
right during this transformation there's
a lot of fun right fear and certainty
and doubt and so you have to make sure
that you you kind of everybody needs to
feel like they're part of what's going
on and so what we did was create a
program called me and Arvest and that
program really was about defining rope
profiles learning Journeys and making
everybody feel like they knew what their
path was as part of our transformation
oh this is awesome thank you and better
you know I've been talking about the
importance of of time to market for
example what do you feel is critical for
uploving Journey and what is the role of
Google Cloud
first thank you very much for allowing
to share a little bit from what about
what we learned through the app loving
Journey come from I'm incredibly proud
to be a part of
um at uploading we have a
straightforward yet ambitious mission to
connect businesses big and small to
customers all over the world we do it
through software and AI techniques that
allow our clients to grow reach and
monetize their audiences
the tech industry has often been
compared to the survival of the fittest
and I'm very proud to say that in the
last 11 years app loving hasn't just
survived it has thrived in that industry
I think our secret sauce is a culture of
innovation this culture allowed us to
respond to the changes in our customers
demands changing changes in ecosystems
and most importantly constant change in
technological advancements that we
observed
I think partnering with Google has been
a game-changing partnership for us the
experimentation ecosystem and the
Frameworks that Google has provided
allowed us to nurture the culture of
innovation in two major ways
first we were able to run a plethora of
experiments much much faster time
between an idea a test and further
refinement or going to other ideas has
reduced significantly
the second point was how flexible the
platform is I really believe that it is
a very dangerous thing to be bound by
the infrastructure rigidity that may
impose limitations on the algorithms on
the math on the ideas that you want to
try working with Google Cloud allowed us
not to think about the infrastructural
limitations but instead to focus on
ideas and their implementations as they
were conceived to sum up I think Google
was a force multiplier in creating our
culture of innovation
the tech industry will keep evolving
and I strongly believe that with the
help of Google Cloud engine app loving
will be able to remain on the Forefront
of that evolution
thank you and this is actually a great
segue to come around because snap have
been a long time Google Cloud customers
and I think it's fair to say that you
know Google cloud and snap grew together
in some sense so maybe come on can you
tell a little bit how we co-innovated
and push the boundaries
that's a great question thanks for
having me
um you know Snapchat is started on app
engine
um when I joined a snap nine years ago
the first thing that got my attention
was how is this possible that it's such
a very very a small team we were able to
like handle such a huge traffic and
serving tens of millions of users and
then there was like this joke that you
would say internally that it's true that
our team is very small but we have an
army of sres and Google Engineers that
are helping us to scale the app as a
snap grew and our organization grew and
we wanted to basically better
customization of our workloads and be
able to have like better failure
isolation we went through this journey
that many companies go through which is
like basically breaking up the monolith
into service oriented architecture so we
heavily embraced gke and
kubernetes-based Technologies and Google
was a great partner to help us to
migrate from App engine to uh gke
platform
um and I can say like Google played an
instrumental role basically helping us
go from like two Engineers working on
the infrastructure to now like having
like an engineering size of like 2 000
people
yeah that's definitely uh sounds
familiar but it was amazing like having
that Journey
and
Omar better was mentioning the
importance of flexibility of the
platform and Innovation can you maybe go
a little bit more to details of how
using gke has been valuable for
uploading yeah of course thank you ahead
um
Apple even started off in really a
traditional way we had data centers uh
bare metal service providers and our you
know our business was continuing to grow
however it felt like our infrastructure
was coasting a bit and so we made that
decision in late 2020 to migrate to
Google Cloud
we did that in three months it was a fun
journey and
it ended up being a immediate impact for
our business
from there our AI advertising engine was
continued to be built up on and this
year we decided
um that we needed to do something new we
needed something to be flexible and
scalable
and for us that ended up being gke and
with the power of using gke with gpus
uh we were able to scale from
a few instances in one region as an
experiment to worldwide production
rollout in really just a few weeks
this was really phenomenal and you know
to boss's point of you know you don't
want to be limited by the tools you
really want to accelerate and grow the
business and we really felt that way
with the power of Google Cloud
um
ultimately you know we've you know
leveraged other tools as well like
serverless compute and
um for us it's it's been an amazing
experience and
I would say at least for me personally
like at life changing yeah
it's great I mean I wasn't sure if
you're being cynical it was no attorney
or not but
that's definitely good yeah you know
what but with all this scale I think you
know one thing that I often hear from
our customers is
how do you optimize cost per performance
like does how do you reason about it in
the trade-offs Cameron maybe you can
tell us a little bit of snaps guiding
principles with how you approach that
excellent question you know like any
company that goes through explosive
growth managing cost of operations is
like one of the huge problems that you
want to make sure that things remain
within reason
um we are very regimented about it and
we think about the unit of value that we
provide to our customers
um so we we innovated on this idea of
like scaling metrics for costs and
basically we measure the infrastructure
costs in terms of the unit of value that
we provide like for example what is the
cost of a thousand snaps that you send
what is the cost of like a thousand
chats that we send and then we monitor
this and we try to figure out a reason
about like the fluctuations on how we
can actually improve it in that lens so
there's a bunch of tools that we used
like for example gcp profiling is one of
the key products that we use also the
the cloud Ops tooling that gcp provides
there's a lot of fantastic Solutions
there the gcp price
recommendations for like cost savings is
another fantastic solutions that we use
to basically Monitor and improve things
continuously
yes and you're mentioning uh you know
the recommendation so I think not many
people know but they're actually within
Google cloud of course we've been uh
leveraging AI for a long time of course
like for example with those
recommendations that are available
but I think you know you're introducing
here like an important point about the
uh the value right that each action has
because I want to think that we
we also hear something with customers
like how do you justify modernization
like taking a monolith right and
bringing it to microservices is it's not
an easy task
uh Laura I really like to know you
shared with me how you guys are thinking
about how you measure success maybe you
can share with us that yeah absolutely
um so it's it's similar to some degree
um and so part of what we try to do is
think about from a metrics perspective
you know everyone you might look at it
from cost because we care about cost and
so we partnered with our finance team to
look at it in two ways pure
infrastructure and uh savings and we'll
say related costs from moving from a
data center to to cloud and so we took
that and said you know normal you've got
Hardware you've got Cloud compute you've
got
software and software and where can we
have savings from things that we didn't
need anymore because it was built into
the cloud that's one layer but then we
took the next layer which was really
standard around one of the things that
we're delivering that's valued to the
business so we built AI models around uh
fraud and fraud prevention and so we
take that and say well how much will
that impact the business over what
period of time and so we look at it from
that perspective so the layer of the way
that we did metrics was twofold so it
was just core infrastructure layer and
then business value and so we have four
or five right now ai use cases that are
actually driving how we're measuring the
value back to the business so it's fraud
contact center and a couple of others
but
I think that's really interesting
because you know sometimes people think
that you know there's those digital
natives like Snap and they have to to
tackle everything and have different set
of problems like and here in this panel
we actually see that there are so many
things that are actually more similar
and then one would think both with the
planning and the challenging and the
challenges and also how we measure cost
in value
um so I think we have like time for one
more question about the the theme of
Google next is a
the new way to Cloud so what is like
something that maybe you're excited
about into the future thank you yeah as
I look at all the announcements that
Google has made as I look at the
projects and the tools around uh you
know the conference and generally as I
look at the new research specifically in
gen AI field in general
I think we came to a very rare
inflection point where algorithms meet
scalable infrastructure meet amazing
tooling and I believe that this
inflection point will lead to explosion
of new ideas increased performance and
hopefully will improve Human Condition
hopefully I agree with that and thank
you so much for joining really enjoyed
the conversation and really a big thank
you for the partnership I think you know
like I've started in the beginning uh
within Google Cloud customer empathy and
working with all our customers really
shapes our products and services and we
would love you know the same way we work
with uh
with them is to of course to work with
all of you
so
to to wrap up we really would like to
encourage all of you to start and
explore Cloud operations Cloud run and
gke
start using the latest and greatest
we believe the few the future is now
possibilities are endless for Innovation
for your operations and with containers
and AI thank you so much for joining us
foreign